[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a korean action comedy
film called justice high
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
at the beginning of the movie a high
school girl named jenny is walking down
the hallway as students cheer for her
jenny is short-tempered and cannot take
it when people bully the ones who are
weaker than them she has recently beaten
up some guys for the same reason and has
been suspended for getting into too many
fights the guys stop her outside the
school but are too scared to anger her
they simply ask her to keep her promise
and never return to the school jenny's
father brac is a black belt in karate
who owns a judo training institution
because of his influence she has been
trained in several forms of martial arts
from a young age this is also the reason
why she never loses when she fights with
the bullies the father and daughter go
to a new school to be transferred the
teacher accepts jenny's admission but
asks her to attend the school only after
a week because of the midterm
examinations she also warns jenny
against fighting because only last week
a bully was suspended for violent
behavior her father explains that jenny
isn't a bully in contrast she likes to
fight the bullies because they torture
the weaker ones after the meeting jenny
is annoyed at her father for telling the
teacher about her past brac explains
that there are bound to be bullies in
the new school as well hence jenny must
learn to have patience and compromise
outside the school premises a group of
students is beating up a guy named alex
just because he refused to let them
cheat off of his paper in a test jenny
films a video of the commotion but is
spotted by one of the guys in the
process she initially just wants to take
the bullying to the principal and solve
it the right way however when the girls
threaten to beat her up she resorts to
her old ways she dodges their attacks
efficiently and fights them with little
to no effort alex is stunned to see
someone so brave and powerful a week
later is jenny's first day at school the
guys who were beaten up by her are also
in her class they turn around trying to
avoid her embarrassed by the fact that
they were defeated by a girl jenny
notices that alex is also one of her
classmates he is delighted to meet her
again and tries to start a conversation
but jenny ignores him after school he
approaches her and thanks her for saving
him in turn jenny orders him to stay
away from her if he is really thankful
in the following scene we see alex's
mother serving a mean customer in their
restaurant the man is drunk and refuses
to pay for the food when he shoves her
to the ground alex steps up to help his
mother however the customer gets
aggressive and hits him as well in the
end he walks away without paying alex's
father died a few years ago and ever
since they have been getting such
customers quite often since they cannot
defend themselves the mother and son are
often physically abused the next day at
school a popular senior girl named
shannon stops jenny in the hallways and
asks for her phone she wants to delete
the video of her friends bullying alex
the other day when jenny refuses shannon
raises her hand to slap her but jenny
with her fast reflexes catches it and
shoves her to the floor by the end of it
shannon is left humiliated in front of
everyone
later that day alex approaches jenny
again and asks her to teach him to fight
at first she is reluctant but when he
reveals that he wants to protect his
mother she brings him to her father's
judo class brac makes him fill out a
form and invites him to join the class
starting the next day he even hands
jenny some money for bringing a new
student then we are introduced to the
president of the school's student
council ron the principal praises him
for handling his position well but in
reality all the bullies of the school
are ron's minions he supports them and
saves them when things get out of hand
ron is looking to join a local gang soon
he is best friends with a guy named
harry they have known each other since
their childhood the friends started to
fight people as a form of self-defense
but lately ron has changed harry doesn't
like hitting and mugging the students
for no reason which has caused a rift in
their relationship one day they are in
ron's office when shannon comes in
complaining about jenny she wants them
to teach her a lesson for humiliating
her the three are in a love triangle
where ron likes shannon but she likes
harry the guys promise to punish jenny
for disrespecting shannon after school
alex goes to the judo class only a
minute into the training he realizes
that it isn't going to be easy he is
made to do push-ups skip and stretch to
the best of his ability jenny keeps him
company and trains with him forcing him
to do better alex is so sore from the
practice that he can barely walk to
school the next day jenny makes fun of
him saying that it will get tougher with
time during the break between classes
two guys call jenny tyron's office she
meets ron and harry and realizes that
they have called her because of the
dispute with shannon even though they
are powerful seniors jenny isn't
intimidated by them in the least which
piques harry's interest when asked why
she shoved shannon she confidently
answers that she was only defending
herself she also tells them about the
four students who ganged up on alex ron
is infuriated by her behavior but harry
asks her to apologize she does so and
leaves even though it is clear that she
doesn't mean it because harry cut his
words ron tries to call him out but he
is dismissed although ron is the
president people respect harry more than
him much to his annoyance then we see
alex and jenny in the judo class alex
thinks it is strange that she doesn't
have any friends even though she is
smart beautiful and strong jenny tells
alex to stop simping and answers that
letting people into her life will only
give them the power to walk out of it
alex in turn says that the memories will
stay even if people leave jenny is
touched by his words but doesn't express
it in the evening ron shannon harry and
their group go to a restaurant to
welcome chris the guy who was suspended
for bullying they drink smoke and have
fun except harry who doesn't feel
comfortable talking about beating people
up at the party ron is clearly jealous
that shannon likes harry instead of him
when he and harry are alone he reveals
that he is joining a gang he has already
met the leader but is yet to pay money
to get in harry calmly tells him that it
is not a good idea but when he doesn't
listen they get into an altercation the
next day at school a gangster named tay
comes to meet ron he threatens to pay
the entrance fee as soon as possible tay
is more powerful than all of his minions
combined so ron is cautious around him
although ron is dying to be in the gang
tay wants harry to join them he knows
what harry is capable of and even offers
to excuse the entrance fee for him
however harry tells him off and walks
away when tay leaves ron is angered and
in the mood to hit someone
coincidentally he chooses alex and asks
chris to bring him to the office two
boys approach alex and terrorize him to
come with them harry stops them and asks
them to refuse ron's orders chris sees
this and beats harry up for trying to
act like he is higher than rod just then
jenny arrives and asks alex to come to
judo class quickly when chris stops her
she beats him up harry is in shock to
see that she can fight better than him
he finds her even more attractive than
he did earlier later he asks alex to
take him to brax judo class and enrolls
to train with alex and jenny on the
first day she asks him why he is being
so nice to them when he is also part of
the bullies harry claims that he has
left that group and wants to learn to
defend himself the next day shannon and
jenny bump into each other on the stairs
shannon calls her out for not wishing
her a good morning even though she is a
senior harry interrupts them and asks
jenny to go to her class an angered
shannon questions him why he has been so
distant lately she confesses her love to
him and complains about him not picking
up her calls harry however clearly tells
her that she is only a friend
that evening jenny and harry are alone
in the class when she asks him about his
true intentions he mentions that he used
to box when he was in middle school and
just wants to continue his training
knowing that he used to be a bully jenny
decides to teach him a lesson and
challenges him to a boxing match
initially harry tries to intimidate her
but cannot make a single hit she defeats
him easily and tells him that power
without justice is merely violence
in the following scene ron gets a call
from tay who pressures him to hand in
the entrance money starting that day ron
and his minions threaten and terrorize
the kids in the school to collect money
alex sees them troubling one of his
classmates and tries to stop the bullies
however he is still not trained enough
to overpower them hence they beat him up
that evening he goes to judo class and
tells brac everything that is happening
in school the scene is followed by a
montage of alex and harry working hard
to train they form a healthy competition
between each other which helps them even
more one day brac goes to another town
for work leaving the kids on their own
they go to the movies and then to the
arcade and have a lot of fun following
that harry takes them to his favorite
place which happens to be alex's
mother's restaurant she is overjoyed
that her son finally has friends on
their way back home harry and jenny stop
by a grocery store while talking harry
reveals that his boxing teacher used to
physically abuse him every day it took
him two years to get out of the toxic
environment he was sad and lonely when
he became friends with people who were a
bad influence jenny understands that he
is trying to change and is ready to help
him with the process the next day at
school harry asks ron what he is up to
ron reveals that he has finally paid the
gang leader and has joined them starting
tomorrow he's going to work under them
and hence the gang will be ruling the
entire school harry is furious at his
friend and asks him to change his
decision the two get into an argument
which turns into a physical fight in no
time an angered ron threatens to hurt
jenny knowing that harry likes her later
ron asks shannon to help him capture
jenny in turn for him helping her get
with harry while jenny is in the
classroom she gets a text from shannon
who calls her to the student council
office on reaching there she has served
a drugged tea shannon apologizes to her
for everything she has done until now
when jenny is about to drink the tea
shannon pushes it away realizing that
what she is doing is wrong ron barges in
and slaps shannon in the face for not
going through with the plan then chris
traps jenny in a headlock and ron throws
a few punches at her she struggles to
breathe in the hold and cannot defend
herself
somewhere else alex overhears the
bullies in his class talking about ron
and jenny he realizes that she is in
trouble and runs to tell harry harry
calls ron who asks him to come to the
school if he wants to save her upon
reaching the school's auditorium harry
and alex are surrounded by chris and his
minions the bullies attack them but this
time the two are trained to defend
themselves they get hit quite a lot but
by the end of the fight they manage to
defeat all of the bullies after that
they rush to the student council office
and see ron has tied up jenny to a chair
he threatens to kill her if the guys
come closer or try to call the police he
then makes harry kneel in front of him
and kicks him repeatedly alex steps
forward and attacks him using one of the
tricks he was taught by brac however ron
overpowers him eventually by now jenny
has managed to free herself and is ready
to fight ron he might be stronger than
the guys but in comparison to jenny he
is only a mere bully she showers him
with attacks and beats him easily in the
last scene we see that brax judo class
has several women trainees learning
self-defense alex and jenny wait for
their turn while harry is enrolling a
teenager in the class
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching